This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello. Hello. Hello. This is Gemma. This is also Gemma. This is a third Gemma. This is Gemma. Which gemma? Which one? I don't know about that. Tell us, who is the real gemma? Okay, if you guess, then you are a very good listener of the podcast. I am the real gemma.
But I do have three amazing friends on this episode. Would we like to do some introductions for this episode of Girl Talk? I think Erin should go first. She's the most seasoned podcast A, listener, B, guest. Hello, good day. It's Erin again. It feels like yesterday I recorded my last potty. Also a girl talk.
Also a girl talk. Back again. I was just so good at the first time. Totally didn't derail the whole episode at all in any way, shape or form. And if you didn't listen to that episode, you should go and listen to it. It's great. It's a great episode. I really love that episode.
I listened to it on my bike to work the other day. So Erin has been on the podcast twice before, most recently. girl talk. This is another girl talk, another girl's trip because I, in my mom's word, in my mom's words, cannot stay away from my camera life and my camera friends. Which there's nothing wrong with. Love your mom. Bye. But she's probably right. But I also love you guys heaps. So we've got Aaron. We have another guest who has also been on the podcast before. Hello, it's me. Um, Phoebe. Who is it? How do I introduce myself? You just do it. Just say one fun fact about you, you know. What's a fun factor? Is your favorite color?
What's your aura color? Oh, my aura color is pink. Baby pink, soft pink. But yes, I'm here with my friends and we're in Nusa. Can we say that? Yeah, yeah, we're in Nusa. Maybe we probably should have said that to begin with. Yeah.
Before we... Maybe we'll introduce our final person, which would be... Kate. And then we can talk about what we're all doing here. Kate. Um, my aura color is... No. Yes, no, I love it.
Wait, what do I say about myself? Your oracle is aquamarine. So like light blue for the ocean, because we're on a beach holiday at the ocean. We are. And Kate was on my second episode ever of the podcast. Like about a year ago, so I'm old news. Okay. Old news.
She's old news, peeps. So basically we are all here on a beach holiday that was Phoebe's idea. And we thought, let's get away from all the cold and dreary. wetness of where we all live. We need some sunshine. We do need some sunshine. Come to the sunshine state. Not an ad.
I don't want to leave now. No, I don't want to leave either. I think I've ruined my months of winter ahead. Yeah. We've only been here for like where it's a 48 hour trip. But we are other boat riders. Yeah. We have ridden in at least two boats while we've been here.
But like twice on one of them. And in both occasions one of us was drinking. I would like to say I was not drinking. on either boat. On either boat. I've been on the little shout out to heaps normal beer, not an ad. But if you want to sponsor us. Heaps normal, heaps normal, alcoholic free beer, fantastic, delicious.
I have been on the alcoholic beer by the name of Asahi. Do you know it? I do. I know it. And on the wine of the brand, Prosecco, on both of our boat experiences. So what are we doing on this potty? Excellent transition, Phoebe. Wow
She keep us on track With three Three in his foot There's four women in this room All of us have had one glass of one I have not yet All of us have had Except for Phoebe who's on the heaps normal
Have had a little glass of wine And I thought for this Incredible episode of Girl Talk We would answer some of the Hey Mummy Oh Flex Mummy Hey Mommy I don't know why I said that
Hello mummy Hello honey Hey mommy With Abby Chapfield. Yeah. Also, Abby, if you want me to come on your podcast, we're totally doing it. But we were going to answer some of the flex mummy questions, the reflex questions. And we did some of these last night at dinner.
Yeah, we did. How was dinner last night? Did we enjoy it? Yeah, it was young. One thing of this trip, we have spent a lot of money. There's nothing wrong with that. I'm not going to say names. I really like the ambience.
Food was good, but it didn't. you know like when you walk away from place and you're like wow wow like that was good food yeah but it wasn't a wow but it wasn't a wow yeah the cocktails were a wow the cocktails were a wow the price the bill was a wow the bill was a big wow I think the cocktail was a fucking wow the food I think because we walked out and it was just like a very quiet street yeah we were like oh it was like a come down it was it was like a come down yeah yeah yeah I think that is where the wow factor tipped side Also, they kicked us out after like an hour and a half.
Yeah, we couldn't even just like... Couldn't really chill. Yeah. So don't go to that unnamed restaurant. Yeah, we would have like had dessert. Like, had a... They didn't even ask if we wanted dessert. Yeah.
That is... Do you reckon that's why you think the... It was just a wow? It wasn't a wow. Yeah. I don't know. I think that's why. I feel like for me that's what it was.
Yeah. Desert always is like cherry on top of it. Yeah. So we basically at dinner last night, um, our darling Erin, um, brought these cards that she really likes and they're a series of like questions that you wouldn't normally ask people
that are really thought provoking Flex. Flex mommy. Okay we cannot do more than another shoutout. I think we're using her cards. We've done four shoutouts. We're using her cards. Flex Mommy. He's normal. Prosettego.
Loose the sunshine stage. They're all just things that we like and we're just acknowledging it. Yeah. They're really good on her website. she's got like three different versions. So this is the question pack number two, which is the first one's like the basic one.
And then the second one's like more critical. And it's cards with these questions on them. So if you do like these questions, that's where we got them. But we thought that to add some structure to this episode, we'd ask some of these questions. Do we want to get into it? Yeah, we do. Okay, well, be prepared.
I'm sure we have some juicy answers. So to kick off the first question, I pulled this one, and I thought it'd be really interesting. So tell someone what your first impression of them was and how it's changed. And I thought we could all answer for one person to our right as I kind of get to know you for the people who are listening. So Kate, what was your first impression of Phoebe? Okay, Phoebe's. My first impression of you.
Well, I've definitely met you through Gem and sort of, gosh. I don't even know what, yeah. I feel like. No, I do remember. you invited me to your birthday as like a little additional person. Yes. Yeah. I think my first impression of you was just, I don't know, super lively, super chatty, super fun to be around.
And you know, those sort of friends that you meet and you're like, oh, that would be like an awesome social friend to someone that I'm like engaged with on a social level and just have a good time with. But then I realize you're also really fucking into spin class and the scene up and the friendship has just grown. And I think now, yeah, when you like dig a bit deep up with friendships and, yeah, sort of cut the surface and you end up as really good things. Because we're definitely mutual. We were definitely mutuals and now we're friends. I was felt really happy that you invited me to your birthday. Yeah, I was like, oh, a little plus one. But I'll come along and I've good time.
It was really fun. And we all got hammered. That was really fun, actually. So, Phoebe, what was your first impression of Aaron? So I sort of knew Aaron for uni. Like, we'd done, like... I don't know where we first made. It was...
Well, technically, it was when we travelled overseas for uni. That was when we first went? No, but I knew, like, we'd been... We'd interacted very briefly, like, you know, like in uni classes where we did a similar degree, both environmental studies, and... I will... Can I quickly preface this by saying, I have a terrible memory. Yeah.
So I do not remember. Like it was a small cohort. Like it was everyone at the school knew each other. Yeah. Yeah. I like I knew of you. And so from there, we both like ended up going overseas. Yeah.
And that was a very, I feel like it was a very intense experience. It was a lot happening. A lot of just craziness. So what was your first impression of it? It was just, it was an intense experience. Yeah. Under this intense like overseas experience. It was.
was a lot. So I, like, we were in Fiji. Can I say where we were? Yeah, yeah. We were in Fiji. Yeah. We went to Fiji for you weeks. For two weeks. For two weeks with a group of like 20 people.
20 people. Um, and we stayed in multiple different places. Yeah. Rural places. There were a lot of strong characters that we met. Very strong characters. Interesting characters. Like the permaculture man.
Yes. Um, so I think because it was just such a like, well, throw you into this random country and you're going to be meeting all these crazy people and doing all this crazy stuff. you got to know people very quickly. So, yeah, that was, my first impressions was, like, you're very genuine and, like, up clear who you are, because it was, like, we were in the middle of rural Fiji together.
And I would be sitting there, like, and it was, like, very, like, five minutes in, and we were, yeah, already clicking. Clicking. Yeah. So cute. Because that's what it was, that's what the experience. We were in a very intense experience.
Yeah, yeah. What a lovely first impression to have of someone. And we swamowing. In the tropical waters and we went snorkeling and what else do we do? We did lots of fun things. We walked down a river. Oh yeah and we were swearing at the miners
who were mining in the gravel river. They were mining like, and we were all recording them and we're like We're going to change the world. We're going to report you to the Fijian government. And the Fijian government couldn't give a single flying shit because some students actually went into the office and were like what are you going to do about this?
And they're like, Oh, we don't care. We don't care. so it was really interesting but it was beautiful it was beautiful beautiful beautiful field trip and it was it was kind of nice actually because I'd been on a field trip before that
to Vietnam and this one was really chill so you actually got to know we were on Fiji time we woke up at 10 we played a lot of banana grams I love that that I really associate that game with you Aaron banana gram yeah yeah I always play it with you I've only ever played it with you
Aaron what were your first impressions of Gemma. Oh my God. You know my first impressions. And they are fucking incredible because they were terrible. But let's be kind of. I can't, I can't, because I'm a genuine person. You are, but also, this is my podcast.
This is your podcast. So I just kind of, like, my first impressions of Jebba were. And no mention of any political parties. No, you can't. No, I'm going to tell us straight. One morning, I was eating my breakfast at college, minding my own goddamn business and two tables down from me, this girl waltzes in with like three people like trailing after her and she goes, oh my God. I just got a Mecca package and she proceeds to
unbox her fucking like huge Mecca order on the table. Side note, to be fair, Mecca does really good gift boxes the way they wrap that thing. But I think she's also your so not a Mecca get on. Yeah, I think She's opening my passes. This is pressure, pressure, pressure. And so she's here. She's unpacking everything, like going through her skincare. Everybody's like around the table's like ooing and aaring and like getting really, really excited. And she's standing there like, you were like dressed really nicely.
Like you had full face and makeup on. You had like really nice clothes on. Honestly, kudos to you. I remember that vividly in college. Always makeup. You like always. Because I was insecure about my skin. So you're like, and we're taking it on.
But you look like great and you have like the full outfit. whatever and I just remember sitting there being like this bitch like unpacking her little mecca order she thinks she's hot shit and I was like I know I remember this and I was like oh what a fucking wanker I love it because that too wholesome like yeah yeah no no no I've told you this before and I was a wanker I was seriously like what a wanker like this girl has so much money like one of the Melbourne girls like she's got like all of her cash she's got a little mecca order coming in every month like and everybody around the table, like, I just remember really, some people who...
Yeah, yes. I should. Yeah, anyway. And they were just like, oh my God. Like, girl, like, the bronzer's so cute. And I was like, okay, this is a lot. And then I learned, because I was telling something about this. And I was like, oh, yeah, this girl, like, what the fuck?
Like, a bit of a bit of a poser. You're bitching about me. I was, I was. But enjoying getting her. But the thing is about, like, the thing is, like, when you enter the kitchen of college, it's like an auditorium. Yeah, it's like the... fucking gladiators and like she'd like put on this show for everybody like unpacking her
hair are you sure i didn't just get a package i'm sure you just got a package whatever but like me and like seven o'am in the morning and i'm like fucking like a little um like goblin a little gremlin over my like breakfast is i get excited when a package calms but wait what was it anyway but yeah you're talking about how i had so much money i was like oh this girl whatever and then my friend goes yeah and she's a climate change denier. And I remember, like, when my first time, my first time I ever talked to you, we had an argument where you were like, climate change isn't real. And I was like, I don't think that happened. No, this happened. This happened. But I've never thought that. Maybe I was just pulling your leg. No, I think you 100% were. I think you 100% were pulling me, like, and I fully believed you.
And I was like, I cannot believe she would say something like that. And I think like, like James said to me at the time, he was like, I'm pretty sure like, you know, like she was joking. And I was like, no, she wasn't. Like, babes, I don't think I've ever not believed. I know, I know, but I think you were, I think you were a hundred times something, but I was, like, so angry and I was like, oh, this girl. And now we're like, I know, like, thick as thieves. So there we go. But I would say you're a very different person.
I would say you're a very, you don't like me anymore. I'm a bitch with lots of money. No. It's a climate change denier. But I also, I'm like, I'm really interesting because I have a very negative outlook on people. So, like, I will judge somebody. Yeah, I'm glad you popped that demo. First 10 seconds.
But you also have changed. But also, like, I judged somebody within, like, first 10 seconds. So, and to see that at college, I was just like, ugh. So when you meet someone, you see the worst in the weather. I meet somebody, I try really hard to find the best of them. And they can be the worst person ever. But this is why I think I'm a good judge of character. I'm terrible judge of character.
Yeah, because I always see the worst in people. Do you think that's me now? No, you're a very different person now, I would say, personally. I don't think I've gotten a mechapack for a while. What do you think, Kate? You've known Gem since. Well, I'm not, Gem's not to my right hand side.
Yeah, well, I'm going to give my first impression of Kate. And since I'm a wanker, I, uh, it's going to be like really, it's going to be really loving. I'm a climate denial. I'm not going to pull any punches. And I love mecca packages.
And I love, and I love mecca packages. So mecca, send them through so I can open them. Mecca, meca. Erin, you kind of really sold me. for doing an amazing unboxing. Everybody was. They were very excited.
As maybe would say, shout out to met her. Hello. Okay, so, thank you, Erin. I love you. I love you too, so I'm not offended. I'm not. But my first impression of Kate was, I met Kate for the first time at Mooseheads.
Really? Yep. And she was with someone at the time. And I remember, one of our mutual friends introduced me to her and was like oh this is Kate Bolter and I was like I saw you
and I met you and I was like wow she's so pretty she's never gonna ugly yeah pretty ugly I was like she's so pretty and I was like she's never going to be friends with me like I just like I was like four and a half years
I know here we are but I was like oh she's so beautiful and you're kind of quiet as well you because you didn't really know any of us funny story there's actually a photo of us from that night in which me and another someone I was friends with got a photo and in the background is Kate yelling at the guy she's with oh no oh my god that's incredible we gotta find it but um it's it's kind of a relic now and then posted in the show notes yeah yeah definitely not um that will not be out the other time but then i um i don't know what it was but i something about
that first impression i was like yeah i kind of like made up my mind i was like okay i guess i've got to be friends with her now i was just was like I'm going to be her friend. And so the second time I met Kate, I um, throw back to our first podcast episode together. Yeah, yeah. Actually, if you want to hear that, this is full story, but basically I, um, ambushed her and, um, I staged a run in to meet her. I saw her coming up the stairs of B&J, staged a run in, with her mom. And, um, so that we could meet. And then the rest is history. Do I go ahead? Jim pursues people. I do. She does. She does. She pursued me. did it pursue Aaron
I've pursued me I think it was pretty mutual oh that's what you do No but like You found ways to like Like not incidentally But like find opportunities To hang out with somebody
When you enjoy hanging out And you're like I'm gonna find an opportunity To see them Yeah which is an admirable thing Because you know that like You know With people that you potentially We're gonna start a really nice friendship with
And you see good qualities In these people that you're like You know Because you could miss out on so many friendships If you didn't pursue them Indeed. And here we are four and a half years later. The pretty girl who was really quiet is now sitting to my right.
In Nusa. In Nusa. Definitely not quiet. Definitely not pretty. I think the question though is interesting because the whole point of reflex questions you don't think critically about him and then talk about the question, blah, blah, blah, not just the answer itself. But I think first impression is really interesting.
Yeah. Really, really interesting. Well, I think your idea of... Don't judge a book by X color. Oh, yeah. That's like common quote. Or like actually take time to get to know people Because it's like Aaron
Well no but I feel like fair enough I was probably a bit of a brat back then Definitely But now we know each other on a much deeper level And I feel like all I don't think any of those things that you thought about me Would be you would say in my main attributes these days Absolutely not know
Maybe I'm still a bit of a wanker No And we never say that sometimes No Wow what a great way to introduce everyone to the podcast So I feel like this next one we'll dig a little bit deeper. What stereotype do you completely live up to?
Completely live up to. Oh my gosh. What's a stereotype about a kind of person... We have to say about ourselves. Yeah, so about the kind of person, someone would perceive you as that you're like, actually, that's correct. Oh. Can I go first?
Because I actually, I've thought about this a lot. So I feel like there's a stereotype of, like, white girls like Taylor Swift. and you're like And I really like Taylor Swift And every time I'm like And I'm actually a huge swifty But I feel like And I say that with absolute confidence
Because I love her Even like this morning Who was like one of you was like Looking over my shoulder And I was like oh my God Taylor Swift was seen in public For the first time in three months But I feel like it's such a thing of like
Oh my God like basic white girls Who like Taylor Swift And recently I've come to embrace the fact That I am a basic white girl who runs a psychology podcast and who listens to Taylor Swift always in the car. So that's my stereotype. Is it a good one? I like that stereotype.
You do live off to it. Yeah, I do. Would you, if she came to Australia, would she see more than one of her shows? I actually was talking to someone about this the other day. If she did a tour in anywhere in the world, I would probably bankrupt myself to go and see her. Every day I wake up and one of my first thoughts is about Taylor Swift. I have a Taylor Swift tattoo. Like, I'm obsessed.
Who else has a stereotype that they live up to? I'm sure that there's, like, many different versions of me. Actually, we recently interviewed someone for my house, like, potential housemate. And this person just, like, everything that I do in my life, like, I'm interested in, like, what I studied, sort of work area, interest. they said everything that I do and I was like I'm just not an original person
they were like oh I love cello and I love and I study in Viro and I like going outside that actually I'm not going to say where I work but like that actually had done an internship for one of our stakeholders that I work oh wow and I thought oh my gosh okay yeah and it just there was just too many similarities and I was like right and she even had her nose pierced on the same side that I have my nose pierced and I thought right oh she had blonde her yeah I was like okay
love you're not coming in this house because I am the only she could have been a really good housemate but you're like I'm not having a feet of two point out no that's what they say you know like that saying if you met yourself you know in public you kind of hate them to be fair and all my housemate said that or they were like they were like
she like no harm to this person no no negativity towards her but they were like she didn't see she they're like there's something off there was something off do you think she was trying to be you I don't know it was very weird just stalked you yeah I think I do live up to some stereotypes like um I don't like I'm like I'm sure there's many there's many like I'm I was one of many types of people that looked and acted and thought like me at the school of environment. Yeah. That's really interesting. Hey, but guys, if Phoebe ever dies, we know where we can find a person.
Also, another thing, like, for example, high school, I was just like the super perfectionist overachieving teachers' pet kid. And I think that lives up to a big stereotype. And all of those stereotypes are true. Yeah. Interesting. Kate, do you have one? I think I sort of do.
I think it came about during lockdown and everyone was like, oh, you know, really struggling to maintain a routine and exercise and that, I fucking live for the morning routine. Wake up 7 a.m. open You know, my line, but the cold of that that girl.
Yes, I know you're that girl. Hey! But I fucking love a morning routine. Like, I love a bit of like, I don't know, yoga or Pilates in the morning, that whole thing, my 30 minutes, you know, shout out yoga with Adrian. And I love like,
I don't know my overnight oats is prepared in the fridge for the night before eat it. You are that girl. It makes me feel put together and like ready for my day. Like I fucking love that. And I find it easy to incorporate into my day. I find that so. For some people like it's a hard routine to implement but I'm like I live for it. It's not that it's a morning routine.
Like I wake up relatively early. Yeah. However. However, I don't have the overnight oats. No, I don't have, I don't like having a routine. I like doing something different every day. I set my alarm for a different minute every day. I just know. I could not do that. I don't know. I think I'm like if I, especially for
like work or something, limited time need to get up and do it all in that time frame that I have like allocated. I just go to bed at random times. I wake up at random times. I eat random food every day. Like it's never safe. You move up to that girl. The that girl's all or just you know, I don't know. It was just such a lockdown thing. People like lacking motivation and things. I was like I need to do that so I kind of stay a bit sane. You should create a TikTok and become TikTok famous based on your TV. No, we don't know, no. Yes.
I love it. Hey, but guys, if one of us was going to be TikTok famous, it's probably either Phoebe or Kay. I am TikTok famous. Not TikTok famous. I went viral once. Your dog and your dog. My dog went viral. And it was hilarious.
Erin, what's a stereotype about you? Can I give one for you? The hippie pants. The red head was a bit of a temper. No! Shut up. And her aura color is red, so I think they're doing something.
That one's not all that true. I know, it's so true. I'm such an angry person. Aaron today, there was a child walking in front of her when we were on Hastings Street in Nusa. And the child was just ambling along as a child does with very little perceptual awareness.
And Aaron just like is like, oh my god, get out of my way. It almost runs into this child. I was so... You're doing the under-the-breath comments. I was so tempted to just walk in. I was like, how dare you? Like, get out of my way.
This three-year-old of no critical thinking skills. You literally can't even see properly yet. Because the eyes aren't developed. The parents need to take it out of the way. Like, I'm sorry. That's kind of child that would run into traffic. Another example was watching you use your phone, pay phone. Use your phone to pay, like, the payway.
Tonight? Yeah, getting dinner, getting pizza. And instead of just, like, you know, putting in your passcode or scanning your face and, like, holding your phone above the thing, it was, like, slam the phone. I always do the, like, and just like, I always do the, like, I really tap it, like, viciously. And then when it doesn't work, I, like, wall my eyes, cancel it. And then, like, go free to. I got so angry the other day. I threw my phone across the room, and then it broke.
今晚？对，去买晚餐，买披萨。然后不是像，你知道的，输入密码或刷脸，或者像把手机举在那个东西上方，而是像，把手机重重地拍下去。我总是做那种，就像，我总是做那种，我真的很用力地敲它，就像，带着怒气。然后当它不管用时，我就，像，翻个白眼，取消。然后，像，接着去。我前几天气得要死。我把手机扔到了房间的那头，然后它就坏了。
and my speaker, it sounds weird because I threw it. Damn, so you're not going to be our speaker and the bowl girl. No, I'm not going to speak a speaking the ball girl because it's all crackly now. So to run for our stereotypes, we've got a hot-headed redhead, a cello, a cello player, a morning routineer, and a swifty. And a swifty. A cello player? I don't think it's my stereotype. We've got a basic girl with a nose piercing.
我的扬声器，听起来怪怪的，因为我把它扔了。该死，所以你当不成我们的发言人和那个球童了？不，我当不成发言人和球童了，因为现在声音全都是杂音了。所以为了符合我们的刻板印象，我们有一个脾气暴躁的红发女，一个大提琴，一个大提琴手，一个晨间作息达人和一个泰勒丝粉丝。还有一个泰勒丝粉丝。大提琴手？我不觉得这是我的刻板印象。我们有一个带着鼻钉的平庸女孩。
No, I know what my stereotype is, horse girl. Oh, you can just look at me and know I was a horse girl. Yeah, 100%. I can definitely look at you. Exactly. There you go, girls. Stereoddust. Do you know?
不，我知道我的刻板印象是什么，马术女孩。哦，你只要看着我，就知道我以前是个马术女孩。对，100%。我绝对能看出来。没错。就是这样，女孩们。刻板印象的尘埃。你知道吗？
Yeah. Okay, that was amazing. Next question. And this one is so interesting because I've never asked any of you this and I'm really interested to hear. Recount the first time you were intoxicated. First time you were drunk.
对。好吧，那太棒了。下一个问题。这个问题太有趣了，因为我从来没问过你们任何人这个，而且我真的很有兴趣听听。讲讲你第一次喝醉的经历。你第一次喝醉。
I actually, I remember the first time I was like freaked off my face. We were, I don't know, high school, party, group of us, youngans and, you know, just having a good time. we look in the mirror and it was the most out of body experience seeing my drunk self in the mirror, I just pissed myself laughing. And I thought it was the most, just the funniest thing because I, I don't know, it was like I was looking at myself and I was like, that's Kate, but that's not Kate. And it was just this weird, like out of body, depersonalized, I don't know, sort of feeling.
其实，我记得我第一次整个人嗨到飞起。我们当时，我不知道，高中，派对，我们一群人，年轻人，然后呢，就是玩得很开心。我们照了照镜子，在镜子里看到喝醉了的自己，那绝对是一种灵魂出窍的体验，我当时笑得尿都要出来了。我觉得那是，简直是最好笑的事情，因为我，我不知道，就好像我在看着自己，然后我想，那是凯特，但那又不是凯特。那种感觉真的很诡异，就像灵魂出窍，去人格化，我不知道，那种感觉。
And I just fucking piss myself every time I saw myself in the reflection. What were you drunk on? No, I think it was like, I don't know, double blacks. Good times. Oh, like double blackson. Yeah, the usual. She was drunk on good times. What about you, Phobs? It was probably when I went on exchange to France.
而且每次我从倒影里看到自己，我都他妈的笑死。你喝的是什么喝醉的？不，我觉得是，我不知道，双倍黑方威士忌。好时光。哦，就像双倍黑方。对，老一套。她是因为美好的时光而醉的。你呢，福布斯？大概是我去法国交换的时候吧。
Yeah. And I was friends with, so I was friends with all the French kids at my school, but I also had my exchange friends. And so these were kids from the US, one girl from Iceland, Austria, Germany, Netherlands, a bunch of Guatemalans on this girl from Brazil. and oh and a guy from Argentina and just different drinking ages all around the world
对。而且我和，所以我学校里所有的法国孩子都是我的朋友，但我也有交换生朋友。所以这些都是来自美国的孩子，一个来自冰岛的女孩，奥地利，德国，荷兰，一堆危地马拉人，还有这个来自巴西的女孩。哦，还有一个来自阿根廷的男生，世界各地不同的法定饮酒年龄。
Different drinking cultures Different drinking cultures And yeah I just remember getting We were actually like We had gotten some We bought some alcohol And then we'd gone down to
不同的饮酒文化。不同的饮酒文化。对，我只记得我们当时。我们实际上是，我们弄到了一些，我们买了一些酒。然后我们就去了。
This like beautiful fountain Like in the middle of the town That I was in And yeah we're just sitting there And I think it was like champagne or something We just sit there doing out bubbles And I just remember being like Wow
就像这个美丽的喷泉，就像在我所在的镇子中央。对，我们当时就坐在那，我想大概是香槟什么的，我们坐在那吹着泡泡，我只记得当时觉得，哇。
I never felt like You know, they must. How many drinks do you think you would have had to get to that level? One and a half. Yeah, probably. Yeah. Like, I never, like, in high school, it was only towards the very end of high school, even that I, like, after formals, like, after parties. Yeah.
我从来没有感觉过，你知道的，他们一定。你觉得你喝了多少杯才到达那个状态？一杯半。对，大概吧。对。就像我从来没有，在高中时，直到高中快结束时，甚至在那种时候，就像在毕业舞会之后，还有after party。对。
They were sort of the only, like, experiences that I would drink a little bit. But I don't know, like, I do remember when I was like. So you do not up to the stereotype. Yeah. I do remember when I was, like, 18 or something. and I finished high school and stuff and my dad picked me up from a party and was like, did you drink?
那些差不多是我仅有的会喝一点酒的经历。但我不觉得，就像，我确实记得当我大概。所以你并不符合那个刻板印象。对。我确实记得当我大概18岁左右的时候。我高中毕业了之类的，然后我爸从派对上接我回家，问我，你喝酒了吗？
And I was like, no. You were 18 though. Yeah, but like my family, we don't drink. Like, we're not being drinkers. And I, it's just not something that, like, it was really more when I came to uni. But I, like, I had drunk in high school a little bit, but it wasn't, it was never to an extreme, I don't think.
然后我说，没有。但你当时18岁哎。对，但是我的家庭，我们不喝酒。我们不是那种爱喝酒的人。而且，这真的不是那种，其实我真正开始喝是在上了大学之后。不过我，我在高中时确实也喝过一点，但并不多，我觉得从来没有到极端的程度。
So I don't ever think it was like, it's like one UDL, two UDL. Oh, naughty. I love that the first thing you got drunk off was champagne in France. Yeah, I love that. I just think it's amazing. Near a fountain. Yeah.
所以我从不觉得，这就好像是一罐UDL，两罐UDL。哦，真淘气。我真喜欢你第一次喝醉喝的是法国的香槟。对，我太喜欢了。我只觉得这太棒了。在一个喷泉旁边。对。
It was an Argentinian. It was actually the castle. Right next to a castle. There was a castle in the middle of town that I was in and there was a big fan at the bottom. And yeah, and then I think we went into a night club and had a great night. That sounds so, so lovely. The rest is his dream. Did you know I lived in Europe?
那是个阿根廷人。其实是在城堡。就在城堡旁边。我所在的镇子中央有一座城堡，底部有一个大喷泉。对，然后我想我们去了一家夜总会，度过了美妙的一夜。听起来太美妙了。剩下的就是历史了。你知道我在欧洲住过吗？
Phoebe today. markets talking French for everyone I was just standing there No but she was really good and then I would just be standing there like drinking my overpriced smoothie being like what? Jemma Pell my name is Jemma Pell Jemma Jemma Um Aaron what was the first time you were ever intoxicated um so little known known fact about me I didn't start drinking until I was 18 good job I didn't know that
菲比今天。到处跟人说法语，我当时就站在那。不，但她真的很棒，然后我就会一直站在那，喝着我那 overpriced（价格虚高）的水果沙冰，心想：什么？Jemma Pell，我的名字叫 Jemma Pell。Jemma，Jemma，嗯，亚伦，你第一次喝醉是什么时候？嗯，所以关于我有一个鲜为人知的秘密，我直到18岁才开始喝酒。干得漂亮，我不知道这件事。
yeah um like staunchly was wearing anti-alcohol until I was 18 um and then I remember my first drink I don't remember getting drunk for the first time because as we have mentioned in the past 20 minutes I don't have a very good memory um so yeah I don't remember because I was I would have been on my gap here so it would have been at some point when I was traveling on my gap here clearly it wasn't that memorable like you were drunk so also I was drunk and like I had lots of times on my gap here where I went out and had a little party and, you know. Yeah.
对，嗯，我坚决反对饮酒，直到18岁。嗯，然后我记得我的第一杯酒，我不记得第一次喝醉是什么感觉，因为正如我们在过去20分钟里提到过的，我的记性不是很好。所以，是的，我不记得了，因为我当时在gap year，所以那一定是我在gap year旅行时的某个时候。显然那并没有那么令人难忘，就像你当时喝醉了一样。所以我也喝醉了，而且我在gap year有很多次出门小聚派对的经历，你知道的。对。
But the first time I ever drank, I was, like, given, like, gin and juice, and it was terrible. It was so, like, gin and orange juice. And it was, like, in this plastic cup, and I was just sitting there and drinking. And, like, I'd never really drunk before. So I think I remember standing up and being, like, oh, that's a bit weird. But, yeah, I didn't drink that much at all because I was very uncomfortable with the people who I was with who I worked with who were kind of horrible. and I didn't really like them and I was like
但我第一次真正喝酒，我当时，被给了一杯，像是金酒兑果汁，那太糟糕了。就是那种金酒兑橙汁。而且是在一个塑料杯里，我当时就坐在那儿喝。而且，我以前从没真的喝过酒。所以我记得我站起来的时候心想，哦，这感觉有点怪。但是，是的，我其实根本没喝多少，因为我和跟我在一起的那些人在一起时感到非常不自在，那些人跟我一起工作，他们有点糟糕。而且我其实并不喜欢他们，我想着。
I don't want this to be like and I couldn't go out because I was like 17 I didn't have a fake ID and I was in the UK and I was like no I'm not getting a fake ID so I didn't really drink Oh interesting I never knew that about you Yeah but I also like you know Having a parent who's an alcoholic it doesn't really encourage you to Yeah drink that much alcohol
我不想让这变成，而且我不能出去，因为我才17岁，我没有假身份证，而且我在英国，我想，不，我才不弄假身份证呢，所以我其实没怎么喝。哦，真有趣，我以前不知道你这事。对，不过我也觉得，你知道，有一个酗酒的家长，真的不会鼓励你去，对，喝那么多酒。
So yeah Interesting But I don't know Don't remember I think I probably remember the first time I got high maybe Oh um yeah That is for another time. That is for another time.
所以，嗯，挺有趣的。不过我不知道，不记得了。我想我可能更记得我第一次吸大麻的时候吧？哦，嗯，那是另一回事了。那是另一回事了。
The first time I ever got drunk was so funny. So my friend Zoe, who was on the podcast, she did the Secret So Lasting Friendship episode. She turned 18 before I did. So of course, being friends, you know, you've got to really take advantage of that. And the first time I ever got drunk, we went and saw a movie.
我第一次喝醉太搞笑了。所以我的朋友佐伊，就是上过播客的那位，她做了那个“秘密长存友情”那一集。她比我先满18岁。所以当然啦，作为朋友，你知道的，你必须要好好利用这一点。我第一次喝醉的那天，我们去看了一场电影。
And then afterwards, we went to 7-Eleven in the city because I lived in Melbourne at the time in the city and we bought these massive slurpees and then she was like, do you want to have a little thing to drink? And I was like, okay. And I'd had like a drunk before, but I was like, okay. And she bought those tiny little bottles of gin, which is such a dead giveaway that someone is buying alcohol for someone else.
然后看完之后，我们去了市里的7-Eleven，因为我当时住在墨尔本市区，我们买了两杯超大的思乐冰，然后她说：“你想喝点带酒精的吗？”我说：“好吧。”我以前其实也喝醉过，但我当时说：“好吧。”她买的那种迷你小瓶金酒，这简直就是赤裸裸的标志，说明有人在帮别人买酒。
And that they're young. Because who the fuck buys those tiny bottles of gin? Unless you're about to spike a drink. Like, unless you're about to either take it into like a rave and you're not allowed alcohol or you're about to spike a drink. So she bought five tiny little bottles of gin and poured three of them into my slurpee, which I then proceeded to finish in about five minutes.
而且他们还很年轻。因为谁他妈会买那种迷你小瓶的金酒？除非你准备在饮料里下药。就像，除非你打算要么把它带进锐舞派对里，里面是不允许带酒的，要么你打算下药。所以她买五小瓶金酒，把其中三瓶倒进我的思乐冰里，然后我在大概五分钟内就把它给喝完了。
And I was like, this feels amazing. So she went and bought two more, and we got another slurpy, and she poured two in, and I remember I was so drunk and I had to get the tram home. It was like five shots of gin, which these days would, like, I would be tipsy, but it wouldn't be drunk. God, I would be drunk. I had three.
当时我就觉得：这感觉太棒了！于是她又去买了两瓶，我们又买了一杯思乐冰，她倒了两瓶进去，我记得我当时醉得厉害，还得坐电车回家。那是大概五口金酒，现在的话，我可能会有点微醺，但不会醉。天哪，我当时肯定醉了。我喝了三口。
I had five. We went and got two more. And also I would be drunk because I drink them in about 15 minutes. Oh my God. And I had to get the tram home and I was like, whoa. Everything was new. I could. I could not do that for my first time they're getting drunk.
我喝了五口。我们又去买了两个。而且我肯定会醉，因为我是在15分钟内把它喝完的。天哪。我不得不坐电车回家，心想：哇。一切都是新鲜的。我。我第一次喝醉可绝对做不出这种事。
Yeah. And I got home and I was like, oh my God, my mom can't know I'm drunk. And I walked in and my mom was still up. And I was like, hey mom. and she was like, hey, I'm like, I'm going to go to bed. And it was like a part of me and it was like, I'm going to go to bed, ma. Yeah. And there was a part of me that was like, I want to act a bit more drunk.
对。我回到家心想：天哪，我妈可千万不能知道我喝醉了。我走进去，我妈还没睡。我说：“嗨，妈。”她就说：“嗨。”我说：“我要去睡觉了。”有一部分的我心想：我要去睡觉了，妈。对。还有一部分的我心想：我想表现得再醉一点。
I want to see, I want to have this weird conversation with my mom about the fuck that I've been drinking. I just never noticed. So, yeah. Yeah, very, very cute. Very, very cute. And I've since told her and she thought it was really funny. The next question, Phoebe picked this one. Thank you, Phoebe.
我想看看，我想跟我妈进行一场奇怪的对话，关于我他妈刚才喝了酒这件事。我只是从来没注意到。所以，是的。对，非常非常可爱。非常非常可爱。我后来告诉她了，她觉得这真的很好笑。下一个问题，菲比选的这个。谢谢你，菲比。
Would you like to read it since you picked it? I don't know. Would you rather be naive or jaded? Naive. No question about it. Naive, because then you can be ignorant. Yeah. Whereas I am jaded and it's not wrong.
既然是你选的，你要不要读一下？我不知道。你宁愿天真还是愤世嫉俗？天真。毫无疑问。天真，因为那样你就可以无知。对。而我是愤世嫉俗，这并没有错。
I am naive. I wish I was a little bit more jaded, but I would probably still rather be naive because I like my life. Yeah. I think in both of those cases, you can be very happily. I think when you're jaded, you can be happily surprised,
我很天真。我希望自己能再稍微愤世嫉俗一点，但我可能还是宁愿天真，因为我喜欢我的生活。对。我觉得在这两种情况下，你都可以过得很幸福。我觉得当你愤世嫉俗时，你会得到幸福的惊喜。
whereas when you're naive, it's always going to be a bit of a scary surprise. I like that. But, Kate, what do you think? I don't know. Like, I wouldn't say I'm naive, but I'm definitely not jaded. I think I would be somewhere. If you're naive, you can get taken in a lot of job. Yeah, that's true.
而当你天真时，那总会是一个有点可怕的惊喜。我喜欢这个回答。但是，凯特，你觉得呢？我不知道。就像，我不会说我很天真，但我绝对不愤世嫉俗。我觉得我处于某个中间状态。如果你太天真，你很容易被骗。对，这倒真的。
You can, like, just be oblivious to things around you. But when you're jaded. You're grumpy. We were talking about this today. I feel like when we were having this chat earlier, when you're jaded, it's really hard. hard to see the best in situations and I think it's kind of like what you were talking about with your impressions of people you always expect a negative outcome because I think jaded
你可以，就像，对周围的事情完全无视。但当你愤世嫉俗时。你就会变得暴躁。我们今天还谈到这个来着。我觉得当我们之前在闲聊时，当你愤世嫉俗时，真的很难。很难在情况中看到最好的一面，我觉得这有点像你之前谈到的你对人的第一印象，你总是预设一个负面的结果，因为我觉得愤世嫉俗。
naturally comes from an experience with with a negative outcome comes from a point of negativity so you're always expecting something negative can I just like sad point that you just what you just said just reminded me of and like something that I have been trying really hard to do all the time um particularly in the last like year um um um But I try and notice, and this is something I learned from my dad, and I've also spoken to my housemaid about, but trying to find little things, like the simple pleasures of life, like little positive things.
自然源于一次负面结果的经历，源于一个消极的起点，所以你总是预设会发生消极的事情。我能插个伤感的话题吗？你刚才说的让我想起了某件事，这是一件我一直在非常努力去做的所有事情，嗯，特别是在过去的一年左右，嗯，嗯，嗯。但我试着去注意，这是我从我爸那里学到的，我也跟我室友聊过，就是试着去发现一些小事，比如生活中的简单快乐，像一些小小的积极的事情。
Like, for example, if I am on a walk or I'm even just walking to the, like, train stop or something, I'll see, like, a cool leaf or something. And I have to point it out. Like, my poor boyfriend is having to listen to me, stop and go, it's a caterpillar! And looking at the little simple pleasures of life. Shout out to Kieran. And like, oh my gosh, like a really good coffee or something.
比如，如果我在散步，或者甚至只是走路去火车站之类的地方，我看到一片很酷的叶子什么的。我就会忍不住指出来。比如我可怜的男朋友不得不听着我停下来喊：“是一只毛毛虫！”然后去观察生活中微小的简单快乐。向基兰（Kieran）致敬。还有，天哪，一杯真正的好咖啡什么的。
The simple pleasures and like seeking enjoyment in them is a really fantastic thing to do. And I thoroughly enjoyed doing it. With both these arguments in mind, what do you think? I would still say I'm in the middle. I think. What is the middle? I know, but would you rather? And I don't, I literally don't know.
生活中的简单快乐，并从中寻求乐趣，是一件非常棒的事情。我非常享受这样做。带着这两种论点，你觉得呢？我还是会说我居中。我觉得。什么是中间状态？我知道，但你更倾向于哪个？我不知道，我字面意义上真的不知道。
I don't know because I'm in the middle and I don't know, I quite like it, I think because obviously if you're too naive, people can abuse that and things go over your head and you're not actually quite, you're not aware of what is really happening around you, but if you're too jaded, yeah, you have this very cynical sort of outlook on people in life
我不知道，因为我居中，而且我不知道，我挺喜欢这种状态的，我想因为很显然，如果你太天真，别人就会利用这一点，很多事情你都无法理解，你实际上并不太清楚，你并不了解周围真正发生了什么；但如果你太愤世嫉俗，是的，你对人和生活就会有一种非常愤世嫉俗的看法。
and it's quite detrimental. What would you call the middle though? I can't. I feel like the middle is level-headed. Maybe like a critical cynic or something. Yeah. Oh, I like that. Yeah.
而且这相当有害。那你觉得中间状态叫什么呢？我不知道。我觉得中间状态就是头脑清醒。也许就像一个理性的批判者什么的。对。哦，我喜欢这个。对。
you're sort of like, I'm aware that, you know, not everything is as it seems, but like, I'm critical in the sense of like that I can change. Oh, I'm almost tempted to say jaded and that's, I don't know, that's controversial. I don't know. I don't know, naive, like, I don't know, Jim, what do you think? I, I would say naive. You would say naive. Yeah, actually, can I change my answer?
你差不多就是那种，我意识到，你知道的，并非所有事都像表面看上去那样，但我很批判，也就是说我可以改变。哦，我甚至有点想说愤世嫉俗，这，我不知道，这很有争议。我不知道。我不知道，天真，就像，我不知道，吉姆，你觉得呢？我，我会说是天真。你会说是天真。对，其实，我能改变我的答案吗？
I would actually probably say jaded because I think what I said before, like, thinking about that, like, when you're jaded, you have. the opportunity to be positively surprised. I was happiest when I was 10 years old, so I would like to be as naive as I was a child. I'd rather be jaded because I do actually think that people and situations often surprise you. If you're jaded, you have to think that's crushing the climate change is occurring. I'm a climate denier. With your like two kids in Nusa as a yummy mummy in your active wear and you just go and get
我其实可能会说是愤世嫉俗，因为我觉得就像我刚才说的，仔细想想，当你愤世嫉俗的时候，你拥有。获得积极惊喜的机会。我十岁的时候最快乐，所以我想像我还是个孩子时那样天真。我宁愿愤世嫉俗，因为我真的觉得人和情况常常会给你带来惊喜。如果你愤世嫉俗，你就会觉得这是在粉碎气候变化的发生。我是一个气候怀疑论者。带着你在努萨（Noosa）的两个孩子，作为一个穿着运动休闲装的辣妈，每天早上去买。
coffee every morning and you go to yoga and you can continue on with your little. a life in your like multi-million dollar match. Okay, maybe I'm more jaded than I think. I am. Yeah. I think I just revealed I'm quite jaded from that sentence itself. But I think that'd be fun. Like, I think there's a certain, I also think it's related to like income and education
咖啡，然后去上瑜伽课，你可以继续过着你那小小的。生活在你的价值数百万美元的公寓里。好吧，也许我比自己想象的要更愤世嫉俗一些。我是。对。我觉得从刚才那句话本身，我就已经暴露了自己其实相当愤世嫉俗。但我觉得那也挺有趣的。比如，我觉得这也和收入以及教育。
status. But I think that there is a certain like level of middle ground that you also see a lot with like social media influences, whether they, where they have a lot of money, a lot of disposable income. And they're like, let's go. And they just like live this. They actually are aware of it And they just decide
地位有关。但我认为，某种程度上的中间状态，你在社交媒体网红身上也能看到很多，无论他们，他们有很多钱，有很多可支配收入。然后他们就说：我们走吧。然后他们就这样生活。他们实际上意识到了这一点，然后他们决定。
Not up to me, I'm an individual Just gonna do what I want For my own personal gain No, because I think they're completely naive So they just live their little life Because they know they can live their little life Because at the end of the day They have never
这不关我的事，我是一个独立的个体。我只是要做我想做的事，为了我个人的利益。不，因为我觉得他们完全很天真。所以他们只是过着他们的小生活。因为他们知道他们可以过他们的小生活。因为归根结底。他们从来没有。
Like, in some ways Like, because of the Like, I don't want to say Because I'm typecasting like anybody Who's a social media influencer So I think we all know like what type of social media influence I'm talking about. Yeah, we saw some of them today.
就像，在某些方面。就像，因为那种。我不想这么说。因为我是在给任何一个社交媒体网红贴标签。所以我认为我们都知道我在说哪种社交媒体网红。对，我们今天就看到了一些。
We saw some of them today. In Nitha, taking photos of them surfing. And their little stepboard and then... Quite funny, actually. We were, all four of us were walking back from this pretty isolated beach area and it's in the national park and we were talking about something a little bit gross, a little bit inappropriate. No, it's not gross.
我们今天就看到了一些。在努萨（Nitha），拍他们冲浪的照片。然后他们的小踏板，然后……其实挺搞笑的。我们，我们四个人正从一个相当偏僻的海滩区域走回来，那是在国家公园里，我们当时在聊一件稍微有点恶心、稍微有点不合时宜的事情。不，这不恶心。
It's something that happens. It's very normal. We're talking about peeing in the ocean. No, peeing in the ocean and peeing in the shower. Everyone does it. Yeah. Very satisfying. Very satisfying.
这是会发生的事。这很正常。我们当时在聊在海里撒尿。不，在海里撒尿和在淋浴时撒尿。每个人都这么干。对。超级满足。超级满足。
It is what it is. I'm just saying it at the end of the day who pees in the ocean, the fucking whales. Thank you. Also, if you're at the beach, if you're at the beach, and you have the choice of going to one of those grimy public toilets that are near a beach or peeing in the ocean. Yeah, you're in the ocean. 100%.
事情就是这样。我只想说，归根结底，谁在海里撒尿？他妈的鲸鱼。谢谢。另外，如果你在海滩上，如果你在海滩上，你有两个选择：去海滩附近那些肮脏的公共厕所，或者在海里撒尿。对，你在海里。100%。
Also, by the time, you know, the sun disinfects it, right? And whales pee. Whales pee a lot more. Fish pee. And you're saving clushing. Pooh, Momopo's pee. Mamipo. Mammens.
另外，到那个时候，你知道的，阳光会消毒对吧？鲸鱼也会撒尿。鲸鱼撒尿可比这多得多。鱼也会撒尿。你在省水。Pooh，Momopo's pee。Mamipo。Mammens。
Mammipoo. But anyhow, these are influenced her types just gave us the dirt. Was that why they gave us dirty looks? I was trying to figure, okay, that makes so much sense. They were just like ill. Because we were cackling away. As we should. We were having a great time.
Mammipoo。但不管怎样，这些网红类型刚刚给了我们一个脏眼神。难道那就是他们给我们翻白眼的原因？我刚才还在琢磨，好吧，这就说得通了。他们只是觉得恶心。因为我们在咯咯大笑。我们本来就该这样。我们当时玩得很开心。
As we should. But yeah, I think people like that live very naive. I want to use the word sheltered. Again, I'm making a huge stereotype and like broadly painting everybody with the same brush. but I think very sheltered life in which their ability to live the way they do is due to their disposable income, lack of responsibility and nepotism, baby. Vibes. Vibes. Which is not to say there's anything wrong with that because I would also love that because I would love to be naive.
我们本就该这样。但对，我觉得这样的人过得很天真。我想用“养尊处优”这个词。再说一次，我这是在做大范围的刻板印象，并且用同一把刷子把所有人一概而论。但我认为，他们之所以能过上那种生活，很大程度上是因为他们有可支配收入、缺乏责任心和裙带关系，宝贝。氛围。氛围。这并不是说这有什么不对，因为我也很乐意那样，因为我也很想变得天真。
So you're saying you want to be naive. With like consuming all my fast fashion, gobble, gobble, gobble. Shane. What is it called? every week and you shine package the clothing brand? Sheen. Oh, Sheen. No, they'd be going something like,
所以你是说你想变得天真。就像消费我所有的快时尚，买买买。希音（Shein）。叫什么来着？每周都买希音的衣服包裹？希音。哦，希音。不，他们可能会买那种。
they'd probably be going Princess Polly, I think. Yeah, a bit more high brown. No, Lulu Lemon. Lulu lemon, yeah. Well, you go to your little yoga class and you focus on yourself because you don't, I don't know. No, there's anything, again, there's nothing wrong with going to a yoga class.
他们大概会买类似公主波莉（Princess Polly）的牌子吧。对，稍微高端一点。不，露露柠檬（Lulu Lemon）。露露柠檬，对。好吧，你去上你的小瑜伽课，然后专注于你自己，因为你不用，我不知道。不，这有什么，再说一次，去上瑜伽课没有什么不对的。
Yeah, I was going to say, I actually love it. Sorry, okay, that was a terrible example. I hate yoga. I hate your, No, who was talking to, I think E.J. and I was talking about this the other day. Maybe it was E.J. Again, terrible memory. Wow. This podcast is really showing this. But, yeah, basically, um, she was talking about this. I think it was E.J. Was where she, um, goes to a yoga class and sees, like, the same people every single morning sometimes. And they'll go, like, three times a day, have lunch, do a little, like, afternoon session and then, like, go home. And I was like, to live like that would be. pure bliss.
对，我本来想说，我其实挺喜欢的。抱歉，好吧，那是个糟糕的例子。我讨厌瑜伽。我讨厌你，不，刚才谁在说话，我想是EJ和我之前在聊这个。也许是EJ。又是糟糕的记性。哇。这个播客真是把这一点暴露无遗。但是，对，基本上，嗯，她在聊这个。我想是EJ，她，嗯，去上瑜伽课，有时每天早上都会看到同样的人。他们甚至会一天去三次，吃午餐，做一点，像，下午的课程然后，像，回家。我当时想，能那样生活简直是。纯粹的极乐。
So Erin wants to be naive. The applaudy's mom. The applaudy's mom. Me and Kate want to be jaded. You too want to be naive. Yeah. Yeah. Kate's going to read the next question.
所以亚伦想变得天真。阿普迪的妈妈。阿普迪的妈妈。我和凯特想变得愤世嫉俗。你们俩想变得天真。对。对。凯特来读下一个问题。
It would probably be less anxious if I was naive. 110%. Less anxiety, for sure. Less anxiety. Next question. When's the first time you truly felt like an adult? Well, I don't know because I always, when I talk about real adults, okay, people,
如果我很天真，我的焦虑可能会少一些。110%。焦虑更少，肯定的。焦虑更少。下一个问题。你第一次真正觉得自己是个成年人是什么时候？嗯，我不知道，因为我总是，当我谈到真正的成年人时，好吧，那些人。
with mortgages and real more I have a real job but like real real jobs anyways I like to make the distinction that I am not one of those real adults yet I feel like I'm 15 most days surely you feel it have felt like an adult before
有房贷和真正的更多，我有一份真正的工作，但就像那种真正真正的工作，无论如何，我喜欢做个区分，我还不是那些真正的成年人之一。我感觉自己大多数时候都只有15岁。你肯定有这种感觉，以前觉得自己是个成年人过。
I I feel the same as when I was 15 and I when I'm on the on catching public transport and I'm in my work clothes looking around everyone is in their business attire I'm like, I look like the two kids down in their school uniforms.
我，我的感觉和15岁时一样，当我坐在，在坐公共交通时，我穿着工作服环顾四周，每个人都穿着商务正装，我觉得自己就像两个穿着校服的小屁孩坐在那儿。我觉得，我就是那样。对。这其实是一个很难的问题。你在试着思考吗，凯特？对，我在想。我能记起我第一次觉得自己是个成年人的那段时期。就像，有那么一段时间，我想是在我上大学第一年的年中。我刚刚经历了一次失恋。
I'm like, I'm that. Yeah. It's actually a really hard question. Are you trying to think about it, Kate? Yeah, I am. I can remember a period when I first felt like an adult. Like, there was this time, I think it was in the middle of my first year at uni. And I just kind of got my heart broken.
我第一次觉得自己在做出成年人的决定，感受着成年人的情感，而且我要对这些情感负责。我的天，真巧，你这么说，我的经历也太像了，真的吗？也是我的第一年，对。我倒不会说是心碎，但可以说是我生活中的一次大震荡。哦，嗯。但那就像是我第一次觉得，我现在在这个世界上，某种程度上只能靠自己了，而通常如果这种事发生在我老家，你知道的，在墨尔本，跟我的家人在一起之类的，我大概会哭得死去活来或者焦虑崩溃，周围会有一大群人围过来对我说：“哦，你没事啦，让我们来照顾你，吃饼干，啦啦队什么的，不管怎样，”嗯。但我当时是完全孤身一人。
And I felt for the first time like I was making adults. decisions and feeling adult feelings and I was like responsible for those feelings and mine is so interesting you say that mine is so similar really yeah my first year as well yeah I wouldn't say heartbroken but I would say bit of a shake-up in my life oh um but it was like the first time that I was like I'm kind of like the only person here for myself right now whereas usually if this would happen when I was back home you know in Melbourne like with my family and stuff I'd just be like a crying wreck or just an anxious mess and there'd be a lot of people around to be like oh you're fine like let's take care of you cookie dinner lardi da whatever it was um but i was just fully on my own
我只记得，是的，有一天，只是发生了太多事，我当时差不多正走在堪培拉的市中心，我一整天都没吃东西，当时大概下午两点，所有的午餐店都关门了，我整个人一团糟，我有，我只是想找个药店买点东西，简直乱成一团。对，而且我觉得，天哪，你在这个时刻真的只能靠自己了。那差不多是一个顿悟的时刻，当时我就想，该死，我真的是一个，我不知道。对。
and i just remember yeah one day just uh just a lot had happened and i was just sort of walking through like the city in cambra i hadn't eaten all day it was like 2 pm all the lunch shops were closed i was just a mess i was having i was just trying to get to some chemist to get something it was just all over the show yeah and i was like freak like you really only have have yourself in this moment. And it was just sort of like a moment of realization where I was like, damn, like I'm a real, I don't know. Yeah.
嗯，她有这种感觉。对。而且听到你这么说很有意思，因为我的经历真的非常非常相似。要对自己的情绪负责，仅仅是深刻的情感真的会把你推到那一步。太有趣了。我以前从来不知道。对。而且我有过类似的经历，当时我很难过，在走路，我不知道。
Um, she feels. Yeah. And it's interesting to say that because mine was very, very similar. Being responsible for your own emotions and just like, deep emotions really push you there. It's so interesting. I never knew that. Yeah. And I, but I had a similar thing where I was really sad and I was walking, I don't know,
我想那段时期你是我生活中唯一在场的人，但我会在凌晨两三点左右在校园里转悠。对，就我一个人，我会四处走走，放着很大声的音乐，然后走到校园最黑暗的角落里。这真的极其危险。我会走到所罗门溪（Solomon Creek）那边，然后我只是，我记得当时就觉得，有一次我走回大楼里，我当时在找卡刷门禁，然后我找到了，我只是站在那儿，我当时就觉得，我感觉自己真的非常非常成熟，我觉得自己很愤世嫉俗。我觉得我很愤世嫉俗。我觉得我很愤世嫉俗。
I think you were the only person who was in my life for this period, but I would walk around campus at like 2, 3 a.m. in the morning. Yeah, all by myself and I would walk around and I put on really loud music and I would walk into like the darkest spots of campus. It's incredibly dangerous. I would walk down to the Solomon Creek and I just and I remember just being like one time I walked back into the building and I was like checking for my card to get in and I found it and I just like stood there and I was just like I felt really, really mature and I felt jaded. I felt jaded. I felt jaded.
该死。对。亚伦，你呢？我会说，有趣的是，我有两个，一个发生得比较近期，因为对我来说，这种感觉总是来来去去的。我知道问题问的是第一次，但我两个都想听。对。好吧，我觉得两个，第一个是100%。
Damn. Yeah. Erin, what about you? I would say, interestingly, I have like two, one that happened kind of recently because for me it kind of comes and goes. I know the question is first time, but I want to hear both. Yeah. Well, I think both, like the first thing is 100%.
有时我会突然闪过这种念头，心想：我可以在凌晨3点醒来去散步，没人能阻止我。因为当我还是个孩子的时候，每当晚上10点左右睡不着觉时，我总是想去跑步，诸如此类的。我以前总是想：哦，我真的很想去跑个步，把体内这些能量都释放出来之类的。但我妈从来不让我去，因为她会说：“不行，外面太不安全了。”我当时15岁。完全能理解。
Sometimes I get these random flashes where I'm like, I could wake up at 3m and go for a walk and nobody could stop me. Because when I was a kid, I used to want to go for like runs all the time when I couldn't get to sleep at like 10 p.m. at night or whatever. and I used to be like, oh, I really want to just like go for a run, get all this energy out of me, whatever. And my mom would never let me because she'd be like, yeah, it's way too unsafe outside. I was 15. Totally get that.
你当时还是个孩子。你是个实在人。我当时是个货真价实的儿童。但我总是有这种顿悟：作为一个成年人。我心想：天哪，我完全可以想去散步就去散步，或者，你知道的。那种突然的顿悟，因为我觉得我精神上大多数时候都觉得自己只有15岁。但这种突然的顿悟发生在公共交通上。对，对。
You were still a child. You're a real one. I was an actual child. But I always have these realizations that as an adult. I'm like, oh my God, I could just like go and like go for a walk or, you know. Those sudden realizations, because I feel like I mentally feel 15 most of the time. But the sudden realizations happen on public transport. Yeah, yeah.
一个人坐飞机。对，一个人坐飞机。对。而我做不到，所以。不过我觉得我小时候就做过那种事。比如，如果我要回西澳（W.A.C.）找家人什么的，你小时候也是自己坐飞机的。对，但是，像你自己去预定机票之类的。
Catching a plane by yourself. Yeah, catching a plane by yourself. Yeah. Which I can't do, so. I feel like I did that as a child, though. Like, if I was going back to W.A.C. family or something, you'd go on a plane as a child. Yeah, but, like, when you go and book your own flights and stuff.
对，当你自己在安排住宿的时候。对。对。对。对。你现在觉得自己是个成年人吗？现在？跟你们在一起时，不？
Yeah, when you're organising your own accommodation. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Do you feel like an adult right now? Right. With you guys, no?
什么？我简直就像个绝对的小孩。对。今天我们在渡轮上的时候，我都觉得自己像60岁了。对，我当时就像16岁。跟我那些法国交换生朋友们的短途旅行。不过我今天倒觉得自己像个妈妈。带着我的包。
What? I was, like, an absolute child. Yeah. Today, when we were on the ferry, I was like, I feel like I'm 60. Yeah, I was 16. All my little trip with my French dinitia. I felt like mom today, though. With my bag.
对。你的第二个是什么？所以，对，第一个是随机的，有趣的是，我其实从来没做过。我从来没有在凌晨3点起床然后一个人在外面瞎晃，可能是因为我担心自己的安全。但仅仅是知道你可以做到这一点。但你知道你可以把这算作成年人。第二个是，
Yeah. What was your second one? So yeah, first one, random, which, interestingly, I've never done. I've, like, never gone enough at 3-a-m and, like, wandering around by myself, probably because I'm concerned for my safety. But just the fact that you know you could do that. But the fact that you know you could talk that up to be an adult. And the second one is that,
当我跟杰克（Jack），我男友，一起搬去……我们喜欢的人？一个播客的粉丝。我不知道他有没有听过哪怕一集的播客。我有告诉过他。他不是个听播客的人。我们在上一集的女生聊天（Girls Talk）里讨论过为什么他不是个听播客的人。
when I moved with Jack, my boyfriend, to... Who we like? A fan of the podcast. I don't know if he's ever listened to a single podcast episode. I've told him to. He's not a podcast person. We discussed this on the previous girls talk episode, why he's in a podcast person.
下一次公路旅行，直接播放它。对，对。但是，哦不，他其实跟我一起听过。不管他有没有听过任何一集，总之我要接着说。对，继续。嗯，我们，当我们一起搬去塔斯马尼亚（Tazzi）时，我们在霍巴特（Hobart）一起租了一栋很大的三居室房子，真的很棒。嗯，我们经常会有这样的时刻，比如我们一起做晚餐什么的。然后我们会说：“哇，这感觉像是一件真正的大人的事。”因为，这很有意思，因为当你和伴侣住在一起时，感觉非常非常成熟，因为这是一件，我想人们可能会有很多浪漫幻想的事。就像，当你还是个孩子的时候。
Next road trip, just cue it. Yeah, yeah. But, oh no, he has listened to it with me. Whether he's listened to any of the episode, anyway, I'm going on to check it. Yeah, continue. Um, we, when we moved Tazzi together, we lived together in like a big three bedroom house in Hobart, which was really lovely. Um, and we would often have moments where we'd be like cooking dinner together or whatever. And we were like, wow, like, this feels like a real, like adult thing. Because like, it's interesting because like when you live with your partner, like separately, it feels very, very grown up because it's something like, I guess people romanticise a lot probably. Like, like, when you're a kid. kid and you're like, I one day I'm going to live in my house with my time.
当你心想：我总有一天要和我喜欢的人一起住进一所房子里。但同时这也意味着，哦，我们晚上可以字面意义上想吃什么就吃什么。比如有时我们晚上会吃冷冻披萨和吉比斯（jibis）。真的很好吃。然后其他时候我们会做一顿大餐，或者做个汤，或者非常健康的食物，你知道的。但，对，当我们住在一起的时候，总是当我们做饭的时候，这真的很有趣。但是我们，因为我们在塔斯马尼亚有一间属于我们自己的漂亮大厨房，我们总是。
But also it's like, oh, we can just like literally eat whatever we want for dinner. Like sometimes we get pros of pizza and jibis for dinner. It's really yummy. And then other times we'll cook like a big meal or we'll have soup or something really healthy or, you know. But yeah, when we were living together and we, it was always like when we were cooking, which is really interesting. But we, as, because we had like our own beautiful big kitchen in Tazzi and we'd always be
做晚餐，或者可能在厨房里一起跳舞，或者，你知道的，播放音乐或者只是聊聊我们的日常，然后就会觉得：哇，这感觉真像一件成年人的事，因为住在合租房里可不会让你觉得自己像个成年人，哦，那只会让我觉得自己像12岁。对，那让你觉得你是和你的哥们儿住在一起。对，就是很好玩。对，嘿，你刚才说的话真疯狂，你说当你们和伴侣搬到一起时，这是你小时候一直期待的事情。我以前根本没意识到这一点，但你就像是我的第一批做到这一点的朋友之一。这种感觉太疯狂了，心想：哦天哪，我们已经到了这个阶段了。然后我只是，难道不觉得很疯狂吗，心想：哦天哪，我们已经到了人们都在做这种事的阶段了。
cooking dinner or maybe like dancing around in the kitchen together or like you know playing reflex or just like talking about our days and it's like wow it feels like a real adult thing because living in the sharehouse doesn't make you feel like an adult oh it makes me feel like I am 12 yeah it makes you live with your you're living with your buddies yeah it's just fun yeah hey crazy about what you just said you were like when you move in with your partner it's this thing that you've looked forward to as a child it's just I had not realized this but you're like one of my first friends who've done that. And it's crazy to be like, oh my God, we're in that stage. And I'm just, isn't it crazy to be like, oh my God, we're in the stage when people are doing that.
然后你刚刚经历了一小段这样的时刻。人们正和他们的伴侣同居。而我只是觉得：我的朋友里有谁吗？不，我觉得没有。哦，呃，吉塔（Jita）。吉塔（Gita）。对。丽塔（Rita）。我怎么会说吉塔？我刚才在想我的朋友吉娅（Gia）。听起来很像。对。我觉得这也是因为我根本没有。好吧，你们都有非常美好的恋爱关系，你们的伴侣都是你们已经交往了几乎一整年的人。我们所有人都是在去年这个时候开始和伴侣约会的。你们知道我和谁开始约会吗？
And you've just had a little of those moments. Where people are moving in with their partners. And I'm just like, have any of my friends? No, I don't think any. Oh, uh, Jita. Gita. Yeah. Rita. Rita. Why don't I say Gita? I was thinking about friend Gia. It sounds felt. Yeah. I think also I'm just like totally not. Well, you guys all have very beautiful relationships with people who you've all been together with almost all of you at a year. We all started dating our partners at the same time last year. And you know who I started dating?
一个烂人。我已经不再跟他说话了。但你们所有人开始约会的人都很好，不过没关系，因为我真的很喜欢你们所有的伴侣。所以我根本没有那种心态，亚伦，完全没有觉得“这就是成年人的感觉”。但这真的很诡异，因为它感觉非常正式，有时候这挺吓人的，但这也他妈的真的很有趣。
Someone who is shit. Who I no longer speak to. But you guys all started dating people, but it's fine because I really like all your partners. So I'm not even in that mindset, Aaron, at all. Of, like, this is what an adult like feels like. But it's really, it's really weird because it feels very, official and I think sometimes that's quite scary but it's also really fucking fun.
比如和杰克同居，同居生活真的他妈的太有趣了。我们有很多乐趣。太好了。好的，为了结束这一段，我们要来一个快速闪电轮，围坐一圈，每个人回答一个问题，这样我们就可以向今天来的三位可爱的嘉宾道别了。菲比，你想先给凯特出一个问题吗？给我？不，我们为每个人单独挑选。不，你自己挑你自己的。所以，凯特，你来帮我挑一个。
Like living together with Jack is so living together. Living with Jack living together is really really fucking fun. We have lots of fun. That's so nice. Okay so to wrap this up we're going to do a quick speed round one question for one person going around the circle so we can say goodbye to our three lovely guests for coming on. Phoebe would you like to start a question for Kate? For me. No, we pick it for each person. No, you pick for your own. So, Kay, you pick for myself.
我从牌堆顶上挑吗？对，挑吧。或者我，我直接潜入中间抽一个。好吧，太棒了。怪胎。我该怎么做？如果人生只有一个生存的理由，你觉得它是什么？快，快，快，快，快。
Do I pick from the top of the deck? Yeah, do it. Or I'm just, I'm going, diving into the middle here. Okay, great. Freak. How do I do it? If there was one reason for living, what do you think it is? Go, go, go, go, go.
两分半钟。一个，好吧，一个活着的理由。天哪，我觉得那就是去犯下这世上所有他妈的错误，但从中吸取教训，好让你的生活，真正拥有目标和意义。如果你只是，像，一直在过着一种幸福的生活，老实说，活着有什么意义？犯错，吸取教训。过一种值得活的人生。
Two and a half minute. One, okay, one reason for living. God, I think it's just to make all the fucking mistakes in the world, but learn from them so that your life, like, actually has purpose and meeting. If you're just, like, constantly living a happy life, life, honestly, what's the point in living? Make mistakes, learn from them. Have a life worth living.
我不知道该说什么。我还以为会是墨西拿（Messina）冰淇淋呢。我以为你会严肃地回答。我以为她的回答会是墨西拿冰淇淋。而且也是为了墨西拿。好吧，吉玛，轮到你了。准备好了吗？哦，其实我们昨晚刚回答过这个问题。
I don't know what to say. I thought it would be Messina. I thought you were going to answer seriously. I thought her answer was going to be Gilada Messina. And also for Messina. Okay, Gemma, you got it. Ready? Oh, actually, we answered that question last night.
我们昨晚也回答过这个问题。你抽到的是昨晚的问题。对，等等。你有什么不理性的恐惧症吗？飞机。飞机，是的。非常简单。我不理性的恐惧症是飞机。
We also answered that question last night. You got a last night question. Yeah, wait. What's an irrational phobia of yours? Plains. Plains, yes. Very easy. My irrational phobia is planes.
另一个不理性的恐惧症是那种很私人的，但我约会过的每个人都会在我之后找到别人。这甚至不是，这极其不理性，因为极有可能你约会过的每一个人都会继续和另一个人在一起，因为约会就是这样的。交给你了，亚伦。还有或关系。
Another irrational phobia is that personal one, but everyone I date is going to find someone after me. Which isn't even like, it's incredibly irrational because it's a high likelihood that every single person you will date will move on to another person because that's how dating works. Over to you, Erin. and or relationships. Guys, you've had so much time we've done very, very speed, speed, brown. And let's keep it up. 30 seconds. Let's keep it up.
女孩们，你们有那么多时间，我们这轮简直是超级无敌闪电战。咱们保持这个节奏。30秒。保持这个节奏。太棒了。因为你喜欢落地。
Nice. Because you like to land. Here we go. This is an alien question. Oh, I hate you. Make it brief. What do you think aliens look like? Oh, green.
我们开始吧。这是一个关于外星人的问题。哦，我恨你。简短一点。你觉得外星人长什么样？哦，绿色的。
It's not the question of right. Yeah, I agree, Kato. I agree. I was a little UFO center in the Northern Territory. It's White Cliff Wells. Can you talk about that quickly? No, no. No, no, no.
这不是对错的问题。对，我同意，卡托（Kato）。我同意。北领地有一个小UFO中心。那是白崖井（White Cliff Wells）。你能简单谈谈那个吗？不，不。不，不，不。
You can tell me about it, though? I'll tell me about it after this. Tell me about it after. Um, I think that we simply could not comprehend what aliens look like. And I think that they're probably all watching us, like the Truman Show. Oh, no. The film. We're just their little pawns.
不过你可以跟我讲讲？待会儿跟我讲。待会儿讲。嗯，我觉得我们简直无法理解外星人长什么样。而且我觉得他们可能都在看着我们，就像《楚门的世界》一样。哦，不。那部电影。我们只是他们的小棋子。
And I reckon they place bets on our lives. Yeah. I reckon we're fully just like, there's no scientific basis for this, by the way. This is my personal theory. Yeah. I think that's interesting because as a child, I used to think that we were living in a little tiny box and giants were playing with us.
我觉得他们在拿我们的命下赌注。对啊。我觉得我们完全就是，顺便说一下，这没有任何科学依据。这是我个人的理论。对啊，我觉得这很有意思，因为小时候我总觉得我们生活在一个小盒子里面，然后有巨人在跟我们玩。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Doles that giants would control. Yeah, that's similar vibes. Similar vibes. Maybe your question. From the top. Oh. Make it rock.
对，对，对，对。巨人们会控制的娃娃。对，那种感觉差不多。差不多。也许是你的问题。从头来。哦。嗨起来。
How would this experience be different if there was no drugs or alcohol? Well, I'm not drinking right now, so it would be the exact same. That's a silly question. I'm doing a new one. Do it even one. Would you rather live without love or money?
如果没有毒品或酒精，这段经历会有什么不同？好吧，我现在没喝酒，所以完全一样。这是一个愚蠢的问题。我要换一个。换一个。你宁愿没有爱情还是没有金钱生活？
I would definitely rather live without money. Ooh. I will go live as a recluse in the mountains with some goats. And who you love. Who I love. The goats which is all right. Okay, Kate got that one completely wrong. And that would be it.
我绝对宁愿没有金钱生活。哦。我要去山里当隐士，跟几只山羊一起生活。还有你爱的人。我爱的人。山羊，也还行。好吧，凯特这个问题完全答错了。就这样。
So that's, I, money makes me really stressed. So that love makes me really happy. What a beautiful. Oh, what a beautiful, beautiful and beautiful. In the words of Phoebe, money makes me stressed, but love makes me happy. And you know what? In the words of Kate Balter, all of today, my money don't jiggle, jiggle, jigs. It's cold.
所以，我，金钱让我压力很大。所以爱情让我很开心。多么美好的。哦，多么美好、美好、美好的。用菲比的话说，金钱让我压力山大，但爱情让我快乐。你知道吗？借用凯特·巴尔特今天的话，我的钱才不摇晃，不摇晃，摇晃。很酷。
The amount of times I heard her, we'd be walking on the path. My money can't get me. You don't get on in front of us. Big thank you to these guys for coming on. They are some of my. Of course, any time. my dearest, dearest friends. So it was an amazing weekend.
我听过她好多次，我们会在小路上走。我的钱买不到我。你别在我们前面。非常感谢这几位朋友能来。他们是我的一些。当然，随时都可以。我最亲爱、最亲爱的朋友们。所以这是一个美妙的周末。
And hopefully you guys heard that in this podcast. So thanks, Erin. Thanks, Phoebe. Thanks, Kate. Thanks, Gemma. And thank you, Jenna. Yes, Gemma. And play some of these questions with your friends.
希望你们在这次播客里也听到了。所以谢谢埃琳。谢谢菲比。谢谢凯特。谢谢杰玛。还有谢谢詹娜。是的，杰玛。跟你的朋友们玩玩这些问题吧。
Right them down. And then let us know on the Instagram. Which is at That Psychology Podcast. At that. Psychology Podcast. I changed it recently. Oh. I hated the old one.
把它写下来。然后在Instagram上告诉我们。也就是 That Psychology Podcast。在那个。心理学播客。我最近改了。哦。我讨厌以前那个。
And I also changed the branding. Did anyone notice the... I did. I did. I saw your Instagram story about it. Yep. I voted on the poll. You all did.
而且我还改了品牌形象。有人注意到……我注意到了。我注意到了。我看到了你关于这个的Instagram快拍。对。我投票了。你们都投了。
I actually saw that you all voted. Yeah, of course we did. I kind of mad at the most. Devoted listeners. Devoted. Devoted. And yeah, make sure you subscribe and leave a rating on the podcast
我其实看到你们都投票了。对，我们当然投了。我有点生大多数人的气。忠实的听众。忠实的。忠实的。是的，一定要在Spotify或Apple Podcast上订阅并留下评分。
on either Spotify or Apple Podcast. If you feel called to do so. And thank you again for tuning in. Send it to your friends. Send it to your friends. Like I have sent it to my podcast. My loved ones. My loved ones.
如果你觉得有必要的话。再次感谢大家的收听。把它发给你的朋友。把它发给你的朋友。就像我把它发给我的播客一样。我爱的人。我爱的人。
Goodbye. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
再见。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《The Hardway》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》，也就是 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个高产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。去听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。